[Musique]
oh
non
1 2
1 2 voilà je pense que dans ça doit
aller voilà désolé encore des petits
problèmes de techniques cette fois ci
avec obs fin là c'est pas le c'est pas
le logiciel qui est en cause c'est moi
qui aie qui est pas bien paramétrer le
son est donc on ne m'entendait pas donc
voilà je recommence là où j'en étais
enfin non j'ai recommencé depuis le
début merci en tout cas pour merci pour
les commentaires qui m'ont bien aidé
sinon je faisais tout le stream sans
savoir que vous ne m'entendez pas alors
on se retrouve ce dimanche pour parler
d'un article un article inédit de pierre
bourdieu alors c'est assez rare un plus
de vingt ans après sa mort enfin là ce
n'étaient pas encore nés mais pas encore
eu l'anniversaire des 20 ans de sa mort
au moment de sa public et d'une
publication de l'article dans le monde
diplomatique du mois de janvier est donc
et un article qui s'appelle imposer une
vision du monde qui a été publié c'est à
défrayer un petit peu la chronique dans
sur les réseaux sociaux qui
s'intéressent à pierre bourdieu sur les
différents comptes de sociologie ben
voilà tout le monde était un petit peu
chaud en tout cas sur instagram c'est un
petit peu ce que j'ai vu et donc l'idée
ici c'est de parler de cet article de
lire ensemble et de le décrypter un
d'expliquer peut-être les mots les plus
compliqués où les passages les plus
compliqués je ne vais pas évidemment
être assez compétent que pour développer
là dessus c'est pas le but c'est
vraiment ici de rentrer dans cet article
alors après on se retrouvera aussi sur
twitch parce que je vais continuer la
soirée avec
le décryptage du programme de valérie
pécresse et après si on a le temps eh
bien on va on va appliquer ce programme
dans un jeu vidéo de simulation
politique donc voilà la soirée ici sur
la société ecc va être assez riche et on
se retrouve maintenant sur youtube et
sur twitch pour lire cet article alors
n'hésitez pas à commenter si vous avez
éventuellement des questions sur
l'article naguère combattu comme une
hérésie le renouvellement de la
sociologie opéré par pierre bourdieu
durant la seconde moitié du 20e siècle
est désormais enseignée au lycée dans
cet arsenal intellectuelle la notion de
champ souvent mal comprises occupe une
place centrale en novembre 1995 le
sociologue expliquer en quoi elle
consiste elle consiste alors c'est
intéressant oui de noter que ben voilà
maintenant tu peux pas faire de sciences
sociales sans instrument lire pierre
bourdieu ou savoir ce que perd une
pierre brute due à réaliser comme comme
études et a théorisé et c'est vrai que
pierre bourdieu on a l'impression que
voilà tout au long de sa vie il a voulu
s qui sait ce qui était un champ et
comment ces chants fonctionner même déjà
dans ses premiers ouvrages dans la
distinction donc dans sa gagne
évidemment c'est un des premiers
ouvrages parce que moi j'ai surtout lu
la distinction eh bien il ya un chapitre
est consacré à cette notion de champ
alors par contre par rapport à cette
introduction moi j'ai toujours trouvé
que le concept de chant était très clair
mais c'est peut-être parce que je n'ai
pas assez bien compris ou peut-être que
voilà j'ai suffisamment lutte pour
l'avoir bien compris mais bon là pour
moi il n'ya pas d'équivoque et je trouve
que c'est vraiment un concept très
pertinent et qu'on m'explique en classe
les élèves trouve aussi que c'est aussi
un concept assez pertinent il trouve
d'ailleurs souvent différents exemples
alors juste au passage je vous précise
que sur le monde diplomatique sur le
site du monde diplomatique
tous les articles de pierre bourdieu
puisque pierre bourdieu écrivait aussi d
article dans le monde diplomatique
tous les articles de pierre bourdieu
sont en libre accès donc ça c'est
vraiment
vraiment très très chouette merci le
monde diplomatique pour ce cadeau est
donc voilà n'hésitez pas à y aller et
alors je dis aussi voilà si vous êtes
déjà lecteurs de pierre bourdieu bas
pour pas regarder cette vidéo si lisez
l'article vous même d'abord et s'il ya
des points qui sont problématiques pour
vous mais revenez vers cette vidéo le
champ politique le champ des sciences
sociales et le champ journalistique sont
trois univers sociaux relativement
autonome et indépendant mais qui
exercent des effets les uns sur les
autres moi de cette phrase j'ai envie de
l'encadrer parce que je trouve que c'est
la définition d'un champ un champ ça
serait un univers social relativement
autonome et indépendant mais toutefois
avec certaines connexions avec certains
effets sur les champs et +1 des chansons
sont proches comme ceci plus il y aura
des faits évidemment parce que ici une
pierre brute d'une donne trois exemples
le champ politique le champ des sciences
sociales et le champ journalistique
évidemment on parle de la même chose
dans ses champs l'objet est le même des
questions de société par exemple
est-ce que voilà enfin le racisme le
harcèlement scolaire
la politique publique en matière de
transport une mobilité que sais-je
l'aménagement du territoire tous a
finalement cédé des objets qui peuvent
être à la fois des objets politiques des
objets sociaux mais aussi des objets
journalistique et voilà là on voit qu'on
a trois chants qui sont très proches les
uns des autres et qui vont instruments
parler de la même chose mais pas pour
faire la même chose et c'est ce que va
nous dire pierre beaulieu et souvent je
vous donne un exemple ben voilà le jeudi
on fait on fait un stream sur twitch qui
parle de politique et parfois il ya des
gens qui arrivent en tout cas ici au
dernier d'un stream il ya une personne
qui est arrivé est alors elle voulait
faire de la politique alors que nous on
faisait de la science politique quelque
part enfin vous êtes des sciences
politiques ont essayé de faire la
science politique où on s'initie à la
science politique mais voilà c'est un
peu
c'est un peu le différend comme démarche
bien c'est ce que pierre bourdieu
explique
voilà un historien connu commentera donc
il dit en fait lors d'une soirée sera le
pardon à la télévision par exemple ces
champs sont présents mais sous la forme
de personnes historien connu commentera
les résultats à côté d'un journaliste du
directeur de l'institut des sciences
politiques membres du champ académique
et du champ des sciences sociales à
travers les instituts de sondage auquel
il donne par ailleurs des conseils on
pourra faire une description
interactions liste c'est à dire limiter
aux interactions entre les gens ou une
analyse de discours portant sur la
rhétorique employée les procédés les
stratégies voilà qui a différentes
problématiques possible pour étudier cet
objet qu'est la soirée électorale
le modèle d' analyse deschamps est tout
à fait différent il permet de poser par
hypothèse que lorsqu'il historiens va
s'adresser aux journalistes
ce n'est pas un historien qui parle un
journaliste c'est un historien occupant
une place déterminer une position
déterminée pardon dans le champ
journalistique et finalement c'est le
champ journalistique qui parle avec le
champ des sciences sociales et les
propriétés de l'interaction par exemple
le fait que les journalistes s'adressera
l'historien comme à une sorte d'arbitré
transcendant par rapport au débat
strictement politique comme à celui qui
peut avoir le dernier mot exprime la
structure de la relation entre le champ
journalistique et le champ des sciences
sociales en fait le champ journalistique
est un petit peu en dessous du champ des
sciences sociales puisque le champ des
sciences sociales apporte une expertise
une analyse que le champ journalistique
va mobiliser pour faire un article de
vulgarisation et qui permettra de
toucher donc voilà on voit directement
qui a une structure qui s'impose alors
pierre bourdieu ici bas nous propose un
autre paradigme pour étudier la soirée
électorale mais moi j'ai envie de dire
que parfois c'est simplement envie quand
même d'amener des considérations plus
individuelle parce que je me souviens
alors ça n'a peut-être rien à voir
directement avec le l'article j'ai
vraiment envie de partager cette
anecdote je me souviens d'une soirée
électorale sur une chaîne de télé v
locales pour commenter les élections
communales ou la politologue était
complètement à la ramasse quoi est donc
en fait evel journaliste qui demandait à
la poly à la politologue de commenter
les résultats mais elle était
nulle part je peux franchement le dire
alors des sur stream et sur youtube tout
le monde peut nous voir mais je crois
qu'elle ne viendra pas de voir donc je
peux le dire franchement elle était à la
ramasse et donc ça ça fait court
circuitait finalement où ça venait faire
bugger un petit peu ce cette hiérarchie
entre les différents champs donc voila
moi je suis j'ai des questions à poser à
pierre bourdieu par rapport à ça parce
que les individus ont des talents
différents ont des compétences
différentes si on n'aime pas le mot
talent pour venir incarner ses
différents champs la coi
le modèle d' analyse deschamps est tout
à fait différent il permet de poser par
hypothèse que lorsqu'il dit taurel
historiens s'adresse aux journalistes
n'est pas d'instaurer moi je lui ai déjà
lu ça parle
je devrai laisser mon curseur là où je
suis
voilà son l'avez lu
ah ouais je suis je ne vous diffuse pas
en fait je me rends compte que je ne
diffuse pas la fenêtre de travail ça
c'est un peu dommage attendait hop voilà
comme ça vous avez l'article en même
temps c'est quand même nettement mieux
par exemple objectivité statutaire qu'on
accorde à l'historien elie et non pas à
des propriétés intrinsèques de la
personne mais auchan dont il fait partie
et qui entretient une relation objectif
de 10 de domination symbolique sous un
certain rapport à l'égard du champ
journalistique qui peut aussi exercer
une domination symbolique à l'égard de
ce champ sous un autre rapport par
exemple celui de la maîtrise de l'accès
au public voilà on a le le le le
détenteur enfin le pardon le
représentant du champ des sciences
sociales qui va bien sûr avoir l'
expertise pour lui et qui peut imposer
certains thèmes certaines choses par
rapport à ça donc c'est de cette lacune
violence symbolique mais en retour le
journaliste il peut aussi définir le
temps de parole par exemple gérer tout
l'aspect technique aussi gérer l'accès
au public on peut couper micro ou peu
voilà ce faire sortir du champ veut pas
dire du champ du cadre l'intervenant est
donc lui aussi a eu un certain pouvoir
et donc peut imposer certaines choses
d'où cette autre dimension de la
violence symbolique du côté du
journaliste
par conséquent un plateau de télévision
regarder avec le concept de chant livre
des foules de propriété qui ne se livre
pas à l'intuition ça c'est la grande
marotte de pierre bourdieu c'est de
dévoiler ce qui n'est pas bien une des
questions qu'il faut poser à un champ et
celle de son degré d'autonomie par
exemple champ journalistique est
caractérisée par un par rapport au champ
de la sociologie a fortiori par rapport
aux chants des mathématiques par un haut
degré des terreaux nomi c'est un chant
très faiblement autonome mais cet
automne au mi6 faible soit elle fait
qu'une partie de ce qui se produit dans
le monde du journalisme ne peut se
comprendre que si l'on pense ce
microcosme comme tel et si l'on
s'efforce de comprendre les effets que
les gens engagés dans ce microcosme
exercent les uns sous les autres donc
c'est clair que le champ journalistique
il n'est pas autonome dans le sens où tu
peux pas faire du journalisme sur le
journalisme le journalisme c'est
forcément sur un objet est donc le
journalisme par définition c'est un
chant qui est hétéronome c'est ce que
nous dit pierre bourdieu mais ça
n'empêche pas qu'il a certes un mode de
fonctionnement une certaine structure
une certaine façon de fonctionner qui le
rend autonome sur ce point de la coi sur
ce point de vue là pardon
donc voilà il faut bien comprendre ça et
c'est intéressant parce que ici pierre
bourdieu nous dit ben voilà regarder la
première chose à regarder sur un champ
c'est est ce qu'il est autonome ou
est-ce qu'il est hétéro nomme autonome
il fonctionne en vase clos hétéronome il
est obligé de s'ouvrir il est obligé de
fonctionner avec les autres champs
il en va à peu près du même du champ
politique au sens restreint ben oui
parce que l'homme politique ou la femme
politique ils sont obligés de parler
d'autre chose quoi d'ailleurs ici lors
de la présidentielle française on a
reproché souvent la go jusqu'à présent
de parler que d'eux
comment dire de re de
fonctionnement politique de savoir ce
qu'ils vont s'unir est ce qu'ils vont
faire une union des gauches et tout ça
ça c'est vraiment l'objet même du champ
j'ai envie de dire mais on ne peut pas
faire que de la politique comme ça on
est obligé de parler à saint amand bat
d'immigration dessus droits de
succession d'impôt
d'école de fonctionnaires de choses
comme ça et donc on va sortir du champ
politique comme le fait le change en un
mystique quelque part marx dit quelque
part que l'univers politique identifié
au monde parlementaire est une sorte de
théâtre proposant une représentation
théâtrale du monde social de la lutte
sociale qui n'est pas complètement
sérieuse qui est dé réaliser parce que
les vrais enjeux les vraies luttes sont
ailleurs
ce faisant ils indiquent une des
propriétés importantes du champ
politique ce champ pour si peu autonomes
qu'ils soient a néanmoins une certaine
autonomie une certaine indépendance de
telle sorte que pour comprendre ce qui
s'y passe il ne faut pas décrire les
agents comme étant service des
producteurs d'acier ou des betteraviers
comme on disait à une certaine époque où
du grand patronat il faut aussi prendre
en compte la position kg qu'ils occupent
dans le jeu politique le fait qu'il soit
du côté du pôle le plus autonome du
chant ou l inverse du côté du pôle plus
hétéronome le fait qu'ils soient membres
du parti situé du côté est plus autonome
ou moins autonomes et à l'intérieur ce
parti dans un statut plus ou moins
autonomes qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que évidemment le monde
politique a ses propres règles quand
vous regardez l'assemblée nationale vous
avez l'impression ou parlement belge
vous avez l'impression d'être dans un
autre monde mais c'est parce que c'est
un autre monde qui est autonome et donc
nous avec nos perceptions du monde de
tous les jours j'ai envie de dire ou de
nos champs à nous ben on va trouver ça
complètement différent mais c'est parce
que ça l'est néanmoins il n'empêche
qu'un certain moment les hommes
politiques vont parler du réel et du
concret comme ici on le dit dans le
texte des producteurs d'acier par
exemple est donc là ils font revenir
d'autres champs dans le champ politique
mais le champ politique fonctionne lui
même et souvent on a l'impression
voilà que les hommes politiques ont des
idées comme si ces idées étaient
suspendus quelque part mais en fait non
ils sont ils sont dans des combats de
d'opposition de majorité qui fait qu'
ils vont pas forcément défendre ce qui
devrait défendre théoriquement si vous
voulez parce que ce champ à une certaine
autonomie même si c'est pas une
autonomie totale
en fait la part de ceux qui expliquaient
par la logique des champs est d'autant
plus grande que le champ est plus
autonome donc ça veut dire la théorie
est là encore plus percutante dès qu'on
est face à des chants totalement
autonome le champ politique bien qu'il
soit soumis en apparence à une pression
constante de la demande indirecte aura
un contrôle constant de sa clientèle
à travers le mécanisme électoral est
aujourd'hui très fortement indépendant
de cette demande est de plus en plus
enclins à se fermer sur lui même sur ces
enjeux propres par exemple ceux de la
concurrence pour le pouvoir entre les
différents partis au sein de chaque
parti mais parfois on a l'impression que
les partis politiques et ben voilà ils
font juste du marketing électoral et
finalement peu importe qu'ils votent
pour eux ils trouveront bien des gens
pour qui voter c'est un peu ça qu'on dit
'tiens une partie très importante de ce
qui engendre dans le champ politique et
c'est là que l'intuition populiste saisi
trouve son principe dans des complexités
liées au fait d'appartenir au même champ
politique retraduit dans la langue anti
parlementariste antidémocratique qui est
celle des partis fascistoïde ces
complicités sont décrites comme des
participations une sorte du jeu
corrompus en fait c'est sûr du conse de
complicités sont inhérentes à
l'appartenance ou mêmes jeux et une des
propriétés général deschamps c'est qu'il
y à des luttes à l'intérieur des champs
pour l'imposition de la vision dominante
du chant mais ces luttes repose toujours
sur le fait que les adversaires les plus
irréductibles ont en commun d'accepter
un certain nombre de présupposés qui
sont constitutifs du fonctionnement même
du champ pour se battre il faut être
d'accord sur les terrains de désaccord
et la pierre brute duo fera paragraphe
très intéressant qui nous permettent de
comprendre certaines
comment dire certaines
certaines dénonciation de partis
populistes qui dit mme mais regardez
itra ils sont là que pour leur propre
carrière ces politiciens machin c'est
scandaleux ils sont complètement
déconnectés de la réalité oui nous dit
pierre bourdieu parce que pour jouer
dans le jeu politique il faut être dans
ce champ là et être deux ans dans ce
champ là par définition ça ne pas être
dans le champ de la réalité puisque tu
es dans le champ politique si tu veux et
donc aider d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on
voit quand on a des partis populistes
qui a pressé d'aller au pouvoir et puis
les gens disent bah oui bah finalement
ils font comme les autres bah oui mais
comment veux tu qu'il ne fasse pas comme
les autres forcément pour faire de la
politique ils sont obligés d'être dans
le champ politique et donc d'accepter si
tu veux les règles de fonctionnement de
ce champ quelque part et de d'accepter
les règles pourra pour imposer leur
propre vision
donc c'est intéressant parce que voici
195 me sape à vis de ce côté là j'ai
entrepris la description du champ
politique sans préciser qui lie qu'il y
a en commun avec le chant de sciences
sociales et avec le champ journalistique
ce qui l'en comme avant
si j'ai rapprocher ces trois univers
pour essayer de penser leur relation
c'est qu'ils ont en commun de prétendre
à l'imposition de la vision légitime du
monde social ils ont en commun d'être un
lieu de lutte interne pour l'imposition
du principe de vision et de vision
dominant
voilà tous les trois ils sont en lutte
pour imposer une représentation du monde
et j'ai envie de dire c'est encore
pleinement actuelle quand tu vois
zemmour qui est un ancien qui est je
crois que l'information ce qui a une
formation de journaliste ou d'historiens
a la base je sais plus en tout cas il
est journaliste et puis il vient dans le
champ politique mais certains de son
entourage et certains commentateurs
disent qu'il ne vient pas pour être
président de la république il vient pour
faire un combat idéologique mais c'est
exactement ça finalement voilà il joue
sur les deux champs pour imposer une
même vision du monde c'est assez
intéressant
nous allons au monde social avec des
catégories de perception des principes
de vision et de diviser on qui sont
eux-mêmes pour une part le produit de
l'incorporation des structures sociales
nous appliquons monde des catégories
comme par exemple masculin-féminin houba
rares comme un distingué vulgaire on
pourrait dire nationaux étrangers aussi
par exemple à travers des adjectifs qui
fonctionne souvent par couple
une sorte de dichotomie nation j'ai
envie de dire mais je sais pas si c'est
juste les professionnels de
l'explication et du discours sociologues
historiens hommes politiques
journalistes ont en commun deux choses
d'une part il travaille à expliciter des
principes de vision et de divisions
pratiques d'autres pas et lutte chacun
dans leur univers pour imposer ses
principes de vision et de divisions et
pour parvenir à les faire reconnaître
comme les catégories légitime de
construction du mode social voilà ça
c'est un combat pleinement symbolique
bourdieu dise le mot symbolique mais
pour lui ça c'est la symbolique s'est
imposé au monde des catégories qui vont
devenir légitime des catégories mentales
de construction du monde social quand l
évêque déclare dans un entretien à un
quotidien qu'il faudra vingt ans pour
que les français d'origine algérienne
soient considérés comme des français
musulmans il fait une prédiction très
lourde de conséquences sociales c'est un
bon exemple de prétention à la mine
manipulation légitimes des catégories de
perception de violence symbolique fondée
sur une imposition tacite subreptice
deux catégories de perception doté
d'autorité et destinée à devenir des
catégories de perception légitime qui
est tout à fait du même type que celles
que l'on opère lorsqu'on glisse
insensiblement d'islamique à islamistes
et d'islamistes à terroristes bon
évidemment les mots ont une grande
importance
les professionnels de l'explication de
l'explication des catégories de
construction de la réalité d'imposition
de ces catégories doit donc d'abord
transformé les schèmes en catégorie
explicite catégorie vient du verbe
catégories jeunes catégories en grec je
ne sais pas je pense être plus ferme
allemand je ne sais pas comment ça se
défendre et que j'ai pas fait de briques
qui veut dire accusé publiquement les
actes de catégorisation utilisés dans la
vie ordinaire sont souvent des insultes
q n'est qu'un espèce de profs et les
insultes racistes par exemple sont des
catégories m con comme disait aristote
c'est à dire des actes de classification
de classement fondé sur un principe de
classification souvent implicite qui n'a
pas besoin dénoncé ces critères d'être
cohérent avec lui-même dans l'ontologie
politique de martin née martin heidegger
l'analyse du champ philosophique
montrent que sous un certain nombre de
textes philosophiques central de
l'oeuvre die de guerre il y à des
taxinomies du sens commun comme
l'opposition entre unique ou rares et
comme un ovule hier entre le sujet
authentiques uniques etc le on le commun
le vulgaire etc ces oppositions du
racisme de classe ordinaire les gens
distinguer les gens vulgaire et ans
reconverti en opposition philosophique
méconnaissable voués à passer inaperçu
aux yeux du professeur de philosophie au
demeurant tout à fait démocratique qui
peut comme le commenter le texte fameux
de heidegger sur le haut sans se rendre
compte qu'il s'agit de l'expression
irréprochable d'un racisme sublimer et
oui et quand george orwell parle de
l'imposition du novlangue dans 1984 mais
ce n'est que ça en fait le langage
structure nos pensées et le langage va
va construire leur est elle réellement
et on peut se poser plein de questions
dans tous les champs un forcément mon
studio dans le champ de l'enseignement
quand tu vois certains certains mots qui
apparaissent comme ça
comme les troubles de l'apprentissage
comme
enfin je ne venais pas mille exemples
comme ça mais je dis voilà ces deux
nouvelles catégories de pensée une fois
que tu introduis le mot troubles de
l'apprentissage ça veut dire que celui
qui apprend qu'il ne réussit pas à
l'école c'est qu'il a il à ce trouble
est donc on passe sur un champ de plus
tôt c'est le chant du médical enfin dans
le vocabulaire du médical non pas sur
autre chose que simplement
l'élève voile accapare les capacités
tout simplement quoi on
crée finalement une nouvelle une
nouvelle façon de voir la chose et et on
rend obsolètes les visions pas c'est
quoi alors ça c'est une analyse plutôt
personnels
ceux qui sont engagés dans les trois
champs évoqué travaille donc à
expliciter des principes de
qualification implicite dont qui ne sont
pas dit c'est ça que ça veut dire
implicite pratique à les systématiser à
leur donner de la cohérence ou comme
dans le champ religieux une quasi
systématique cité ensuite et par là même
ils luttent pour les imposer et les
luttes pour le monopole de la violence
la symbolique légitimes sont les luttes
pour la royauté symbolique mais ce n'est
rien d'autre que le travail de 0 ou
encore une fois plus que ce que je fais
et vous c'est essayer d'imposer ces
catégories l'étymologie du mot rex que
ben le nist je ne connais pas donc je
sais pas si je prononce bien propose
dans le vocabulaire des institutions
indo européenne montre que rex et de la
famille de regret qui veut dire régir
diriger est une des fonctions
principales du roi et de régler finesse
de délimiter les frontières comme
romulus avec sa charrue l'une des
fonctions des taxinomies est ainsi de
dire qui est in qui est haute les
nationaux les étrangers voilà j'en
parlais tout à l'heure et c'est par
exemple un des drames de la lutte
politique en france d'aujourd'hui est
que à travers l' irruption dans le champ
du nouveau joueur le front national ben
vous sourit quand on lit ça le principe
de divisions entre les nationaux et les
étrangers s'est imposée très
généralement à tous les agents du champ
politique au détriment d'un principe qui
autrefois semble dominant l'opposition
entre les riches et les pauvres
prolétaires de tous les pays unissez
vous et quand on se demande pourquoi
est-ce-que la gauche étant à la ramasse
aujourd'hui en france mais c'est
simplement parce que simplement non il
n'ya pas que ça ne sera pas dû dire
simplement mais c'est aussi parce qu'il
ya eu un changement de voile a de
qualifications utilisé dans le champ
politique en effet j'ai l'impression
parfois dire les riches ou imposer les
riches ça revient à dire un gros mot
quoi ou ou aider les pauvres directement
c'était des trucs qui sont plus qu'ils
sont plus à dire sur des plateaux de
télé ou dans des meetings politiques
parfois d'ailleurs en classe moi
j'utilise ces moules à riches et pauvres
expressément pour montrer la violence de
l'analyse sociologique finalement pas de
ce que révèle l'analyse sociologique
mais dans le champ politique voilà on
les a on les a remplacés ces mots-là
quoi
au-delà des enjeux communs il faut voir
la logique spécifique de chacun de ses
champs le champ politique s'affirme
explicitement comme se donnant pour fins
de dire ce qu'il est ce qu'il en est
pardon du monde social dans une
discussion entre deux hommes politiques
qui font assaut de chiffres l'enjeu est
de donner sa vision du monde politique
comme fondées fondée dans l'objectivité
parce que de doter de référents réels
les chiffres et fondée aussi dans
l'ordre social par la confirmation
qu'elle reçoit de tous ceux qui la
reprennent à leur compte et qu'il épouse
autrement dit ce qui est une idée
spéculative devient une idée force à
travers sa capacité de mobiliser des
gens en les amenant à reprendre à leur
compte le principe de vision proposée le
grand remplacement ce n'est que ça c'est
zemmour veut en faire une idée force
l'imposition d'une définition du monde
et par sow par part soit un acte de
mobilisation qui tend à confirmer ou à
transformer les rapports de force une
idée devient une idée force à travers la
force qu'elle manifeste en s'imposant
comme principe de vision à une idée vrai
on ne peut opposer qu'une réputation
alors qu'à une idée force il faut
opposer une autre idée force capable de
mobiliser une contre force une contre
manifestation
voilà et on n'est plus en fait on se
rend compte que dans le champ politique
c'est pas tellement la vérité qui joue
en tout cas oui elle peut jouer au
départ parce qu'on essaye voilà
d'imposer cette idée mais c'est de
réussir le coup de force symbolique de
faire d'idée des idées force qui ne
seront plus démontable par des chiffres
et en effet mais quand vous voyez par
exemple les débats anti vax
c'est devenu auprès d'une certaine
population le fait que voilà il ya un
vaccin attendez deux secondes
[Applaudissements]
voilà
quand tu as des antilles vax voilà qui
pensent que le vaccin est quelque chose
de nocif ou voilà quelque chose qui sert
certains lobbys voir dans le cas le plus
le plus excessifs
et comment dire est le résultat d'un
complot c'est devenu une idée force et
tu vois que ces gens là tu as beau
argumenter tab eu beau proposer des
choses ça ne changerait ça ne change
rien pardon et je retrouve là un petit
peu une idée on pourra en reparler une
fois c'est le travail de frédéric lordon
qui qui qui parle de ça je sais plus
dans quel de lequel de ces bouquins et
il nous parle de sa voix là il nous dit
un certain moment tu dois jouer avec des
chambres force finalement essayé de
créer une force plus grande pour
démonter une idée force finalement
quelque part
voilà c'est intéressant comme article se
base d'ailleurs pour ça que je vous lis
c'est à dire aussi pour ça que le monde
diplomatique le publier le champ
journalistique qui est de plus en plus
hétéronome
c'est à dire de plus en plus soumis aux
contraintes de l'économie et de la
politique mais oui il ya des influences
qu'on voit ici encore avec ses news et
l'avènement de ces news voilà en plein
dedans de l'économie essentiellement à
travers l'audimat impose de plus en plus
ces contraintes à tous les autres champs
et en particulier aux champs de la
production culturelle comme champ des
sciences sociales de la philosophie et
au champ politique le chant est un champ
de force et un chant de lutte dont
l'enjeu est de transformer le champ de
force
autrement dit dans un champ il y à une
concurrence pour l'appropriation
légitime de ce qui est l'enjeu de lutte
dans ce champ est à l'intérieur du
changement du journalisme il ya une
concurrence permanente pour
l'appropriation du public mais aussi
pour l'appropriation de ce qui est censé
de ce qui est sans de ce qui est censé
donner le public c'est à dire la
propriété de l'information le scoop
l'information exclusive et aussi la
rareté distinctif les grandes signatures
etc et c'est clair que si vous avez
côtoyé des journalistes ils se battent
pour avoir l'info que les autres
n'auront pas quelque part
et évidemment pour le dit matt aut 6-1
aujourd'hui comme j'aimerais que que
bourdieu soit sont encore là pour
analyser la société d'aujourd'hui parce
que finalement ils avaient vraiment
annoncé tout ce qui se passerait quand
tu vois voilà les journalistes
maintenant dans le change en investit
comme quoi ils sont soumis le fait
qu'ils doivent être multiplateforme
faire des titres pita clic
voilà c'est ce n'est que ça finalement
un des paradoxes et que la concurrence
dont on dit toujours qu'elle est la
condition de la liberté à pauvre effet
au contraire dans les champs de
production culturelle sous contrôle
commercial de produire l'uniformité la
censure et même le conservatisme le mais
on le voit sur les réseaux sociaux aussi
c'est terrible à cet article comme il
est actuellement fin je me fais que je
ne fais que me répéter mais enfin là
c'est tellement c'est tellement jouissif
de lire un article comme ça quand tu
vois youtube qui propose les youtube
short qui propose des story et tout ça
ben voilà en fait il pourrait faire ses
réseaux sociaux exactement ce qu'ils
veulent et finalement bad et qui en un
cas une idée bas tout le monde copie ça
instagram va faire aussi des huiles ça
va faire les différentes choses
voilà tik tok est arrivé alors tout le
monde se fait tout le monde se met au
format 15 15 secondes et finalement on a
un à des contenus quoi et d'ailleurs au
grand dam des youtuber si vous êtes
youtuber voilà vous pouvez
éventuellement commenté donner votre
avis mais
les youtuber voit pas trop d'un bon oeil
les shorts sain parce que youtube
c'était quand même une plateforme de
formats longs de contenu aussi pour
certains objets et puis on arrive là
avec avec un format court
voilà unis uniformise due à la
concurrence tout simplement merci pierre
bourdieu
un exemple très simple la lutte entre
les trois hebdomadaires français le
nouvel observateur l'express le point
fait qu'ils sont indiscernables en
grande partie parce que la lutte de
concurrence qui les oppose et qui
conduit à des recherches obsessionnelle
de la différence de la priorité temps
non pas les différencier mes arrières
approché il se vole les unes des les
éditorialistes les sujets cette forte
concurrence forcenée s'étend du champ
journalistique aux autres shows voilà
bah en fait dans le champ politique il
ya vraiment parfois des concurrences
quand on voit que la gauche maintenant
ils sont tous à donner du pognon aux
jeunes on se demande qui a commencé en
premier mais voilà il ya vraiment une
concurrence quoi qui se fait
par exemple aussi c'est marrant de voir
dans certaines communes
en belgique il ya des idées qui sont
mises en place de bonnes idées et puis
après tu reviens trois ans après toutes
les communes
miss à quoi quelques quelle que soit
leur obédience politique un des gens de
gauche des gens de droite des gens plus
indépendants des centristes et tout le
monde va mettre la même mesure en place
parce que c'est une mesure que les
électeurs m voilà j'espère que voilà ça
vous a donné envie de lire un peu plus
pierre bourdieu
alors je regarde parce que en fait cet
article quand il est donc dans le format
papier moi je les lui au format papier
je n'ai pas pris ici donc j'ai pas voulu
montrer va 100 ça n'apporterait rien il
me semble qu'il est beaucoup plus grand
il me paraît très court comme ça au labo
je reste un peu sur ma faim bon voilà et
bien cela il veut et fini la prochaine
fois j'essaierai de vous présenter un
article
plus scientifique dans le sens
kiwili à une observation est comme ça
une retour à l'empiré ça serait
intéressant ici c'est un peu plus
théorique évidemment mais voilà je peux
pas faire sans vous le présenter dans
cette émission et je vous retrouve dans
une quinzaine de minutes sur cuite ch
pour faire des choses beaucoup plus fun
sur un mode beaucoup plus léger on va
vraiment analyser le programme politique
de valérie pécresse on va essayer de
voir quels sont les points centraux et
puis on va jouer à un jeu qui s'appelle
démocratie 4 et on va essayer de mener
la politique de valérie pécresse et de
voir si on est réélu aux prochaines
élections avec de telles mesures quoi et
on fera ça pour les différents candidats
voilà je vous remercie je vous salue et
je vous dis à très bientôt